there are times when I think the
Internet has changed everything and it's
a whole new world and we're all going to
be doing that doing it this way and
everyone should do what I did and it
will work for them and there are other
times where I think you know I just got
lucky or there are specific reasons why
it works for me and it won't work for
anybody else and or you know maybe this
my my journey is isn't is really nothing
new it's what has always happened which
is that you you make music that you like
you put it out there you get it to as
many people as possible not worrying so
much about where you know how you're
making money you know because you really
just want the music to be heard and then
if it catches on people start buying it
and you can start doing shows and people
will pay to come and see you you can
sell t-shirts and you know I mean that's
a you can tell that story that story can
happen without the internet you know I
think that if anything has changed it's
that it's possible now for someone like
me to make pretty decent sounding music
with a minimal investment in in in in
actual dollar terms you know that the
equipment that you can get now and the
software that you can get now is really
high quality stuff for not very much
money and you know the the technology
that the Beatles used just choose an
example to record sergeant pepper you
know it comes that's that comes free on
your on your laptop you know so that's a
that's a big difference there's no you
don't need a huge investment in money to
make really great music and art of all
sorts of kinds I also think that the
rise of internet culture is great for me
and probably for other musicians who who
have a kind of niche Amishi music
you know I there are so many more genres
of music now than there have ever been
identifiable genres you know you look at
a list of lists of genre names on
Wikipedia thirdly long I've never heard
of most of them but these are names that
people have made up to describe the
music that they like and I think without
the the technology and the the
connectivity that the internet brings
where where you can you know there's a
song in digital form that's easily
downloadable and it's a format that's
pretty Universal at this point mp3 there
are all sorts of ways you can share it
with your friends by clicking a couple
of buttons it is immediately copied and
sent literally around the world for zero
dollars and that's kind of a remarkable
thing and I think that has that is bound
to that is bound to change things quite
a bit so you know I have I have to think
that that has done something to change
the landscape and you know I I believe
it's been you know that that very act of
somebody listening to a piece of my
music designing they liked it enough to
pass it along to a friend in whatever
the whatever way they pass it along you
know my strategy all along has been to
enable that as much as possible and to
encourage that as much as possible in
the belief that the first goal is to is
to have the music heard and the second
goal is to get paid for making the music